for Angela proya it's a never-ending
nightmare in April 2020 her beloved
father went to the hospital after
falling ill he was put on a ventilator
ten days later he died one of the early
victims of covet in the United States
that's what makes coven pretty cruel is
you think they're getting better and the
doctors are like they're getting better
and the next day they're dead
like so many others he died alone no
family members were allowed inside the
hospital to see him because it was
deemed too unsafe that still haunts
Angelina
I didn't see him I didn't touch him I
didn't get to hold his hand as he passed
away I didn't get to tell him I loved
him and give him a Last Kiss
that that never happened and when you're
not able to do those things you're in a
state of suspended morning I think
probably forever
today 93 percent of Americans over 65
years old are fully vaccinated but
issues persist it's estimated nearly 10
percent of Americans suffer from
so-called long covid debilitating side
effects that linger months after
Contracting the virus and anxiety still
Shadows the 7 million and you know
compromised Americans who face a
heightened risk of catching covid
there's still hundreds of people every
single day dying from covet in the
United States those who study the
disease and track its progress say the
U.S needs to do a better job of learning
from those deaths we have upwards of 500
deaths at least of covid every day in
the U.S and we know very little about
who these people are why they're falling
through the cracks and you know where
there may have been missed opportunities
along the way whether it be vaccination
or whether it be being up to date on
vaccination whether it be access to
antivirals this is important to course
correct our implementation and our
response to the pandemic even now three
years into the into it for Angelina any
progress made fighting covid is too late
for her loved one my father was a good
genuine kind gentle sweet generous
person and he didn't deserve to die like
that or any of the people who continue
to three years later
Gabriel ozondo Al Jazeera New York